[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marine le pen à reims eric zemmour à
l'islet les deux rivaux d'extrême droite
en meeting ont ciblé en choeur emmanuel
macron elle parle comme mélenchon
et son époux 10 il y à une
reconstruction sociologique qui est qui
et qui est qui et crypto mélenchonistes
au cdh emmanuel macron le prétendu
mozart de la finance qui n'a réussi en
cinq ans qu'à composer une symphonie
dramatiques sur la ligne elle fluctue un
petit peu il ya un petit manque de
cohérence dans la durée dans le temps on
voit qu'elle ne sait pas comment se
positionner entre eric zemmour et
valérie pécresse sait qu'elle a quand
même dit cette semaine marine le pen il
y à des nazis même quelques nazis pour
être précis autour d'eric zemmour on
peut la croire elle en sait quelque
chose puisqu'ils viennent de chez elle
je vais dépassé le stade où on est
traité de nazi qui est incroyable parce
que bon c'est une insulte que les
membres du rassemblement national
recevait marine récupère les arguments
des des bobos il a mon touch où je
n'accepte pas que les collabos
d'aujourd'hui fantasme sur les collabos
d'hier c'est à dire qu'avec eric les
collabos d'aujourd'hui se sont toutes
celles et ceux qui sont complices de
l'islam politique voir effectivement une
sorte de concours lépine de du racisme
d'antisémitisme du révisionnisme de la
haine des puces sont morts ce qui coûte
cher c'est sa théorie du ruissellement
et bien moi je vous propose une autre
théorie le rouge deux morts
je proposerai la prime
0,5 pour 0 aux sabres pour augmenter
votre revenus leroux tellement c'est
augmenter les salaires et les retraites
parce que quand on augmente les salaires
et les retraites c'est de l'argent qui
va aller directement dans l'économie
réelle qui va aller dans les commerces
qui va aller dans nos pme il ya une
campagne un peu rabougri l'extrême
droite veut rassembler l'extrême droite
la gauche essaye de rassembler la gauche
et la campagne à gauche c'est devenu une
vaste centrale d'appel françois hollande
ne participera à un de mes grands
meetings et interviendra aussi dans la
campagne de cette façon-là jus du ciel
cela ressemble à de légumes il s'agit en
fait de poissons morts flottant sur plus
de 3000 mètres carrés dans le golfe de
gascogne vous êtes cravate et yannick
jadot c'est le nouveau et yannick jadot
qui se présentent aux français moi sa
place la semaine prochaine j'apparaîtrai
comme ça avec un verre leur à la place
de la cravate au mois on parlerait de la
pêche industrielle
c'est merlan bleu asphyxie ont été
rejetées par le margie rice deuxième
plus gros navire usine au monde mais
d'après le capitaine du chalutier il
s'agit d'un acte involontaire le filet
se serait rompu accidentellement à cause
d'un trop gros volume de poissons il ya
des personnes qui m'ont dit on aime
beaucoup vos propositions mais on a
grand respect pour la fonction
présidentielle
comme j'ai un grand respect pour la
fonction présidentielle est pour nous un
homme candidat doit porter la cravate
donc je porte la cravate pour justement
qu'on n'en parle plus pour faire un
mauvais jeu de mots l'embarras de
l'anchois c'est comme à bord du
chalutier de tout à l'heure il y en a
trop on a en a même une de plus depuis
dimanche dernier on a le poisson pilote
taubira le ministère de la mer a demandé
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour connaître
les circonstances exactes de cette
hécatombe le cyclone bats hirai a frappé
hier soir l'île de madagascar avec des
rafales à 235 km heure les dégâts sur
place sont considérables et des
inondations restent à craindre en raison
de fortes pluies l'australie et le chili
ont déjà interdit à ce navire de pêcher
dans l'eure il est accusé de décimer les
fonds marins et de capturer des espèces
protégées comme les tortues et les
dauphins